okay computing power all right
can you give me an example bit louder
can you can someone give me an example
what you mean by yeah they put your path
because usually we were talking about
this is the beginning what is right you
usually we think of computers having
superior computing power to work here
with me right so what do you mean why is
this a problem okay so you're thinking
about if there's a particular kind of
hardware sister right okay all right you
should be careful team - okay because
usually all of you right we will usually
say computers have far superior memory
and computing power and processing power
to human being okay you've gotten out of
the loop by saying it's particular kind
of hardware like it's a really ancient
computer but usually we wouldn't run a
decision support system such a piece of
hardware okay so you escape this up I
hope you've got better reasons than
these two you know quite a bit shifty
okay team and another one
limitations okay before I write that
down can you explain what you go through
the information of everything yep fire
but down their entire building
everything do you guys understand that
give me another example I'm going to pay
ya until you can because for me saying
not sure what I mean humans also get
destroyed in fires too like right it's
what do you mean okay all right okay
that is a completely different reason
what you're signing but I'm gonna pay
because in flexibilities it is a problem
seem to pick up the warrior okay the
food money analogy that's up that is
priceless